welome to best car fixes this is
Muhammad Harris you you subscribe on my
channel my friend are you on YouTube
look this guys rich man here and the guy
who have all car service of welcome
please subscribe share and like Muhammad
best BM un thank you for watching please
subscribe share and like and here we
have a e70 2008 and we need to add one
key so follow us
please it's going to be up and running
in a
few okay
thank you okay so
now we have this car
here let's go key yeah we got to click
this immobilizer car is running say
okay we're going to read all the
information e70
X5 4.8 L 200000 this is 2008 by the way
it's not 11 not 7 right 2008 yeah
okay so now I'm going to go to um
imosa say you need internet yes I have
internet sometime he required to update
or downgrade the c c 3 plus if it's
encrypted how many key I'm not sure
okay cast three plus I have three quotes
on the cast how many numbers we have
three
numbers okay let me clear all this
code all this code here we don't need
it can
fault I don't care about those okay let
me see what you have in the DM people
say look my car after you do the work
you have 15 cord in the
DM all this I don't want to erase
anything you erases the car never start
again so I got to go to add a
key need
internet ignition on
let me turn this one all the load I have
13 volt semi key say
okay start sometime you say you need
connect the device bro and place the new
key in the key you see why because this
car doesn't have CP
[Applause]
it I put put the key
there let me make it clear you see that
the key it's
okay
there generate the
key so now success now generating
key that's
fast yesterday I did one it take almost
one hour
key gener instead of the key nearly
gener
start yes
now I need to go do some thank you for
watching please subscribe share and like
and see you in another video and this
work is done